hello this is a message
to the Hindu community of the United
Kingdom and communities all over the
Hindu communities all over the world
and this is a message
on the back of some of the tensions that
has taken have taken place in this
country between Hindus and Muslims
what I will say is that the overwhelming
opinion of the Muslim people
is that we want peace we want peace with
all communities not just Hindu
communities or uh Jewish and Christian
communities we're on peace with every
single community in fact our religion
teaches us to have such peace
our religion tells us clearly and you
have your religion we have ours and so
on
that's the most important thing and I
must say
uh that some of the things that have
come out recently about
what I have supposedly said about the
Hindu Community are misattributions and
false and if you want to be known
for those who are doing this as people
who have to lie in order to make their
point known then know that you have
already lost
you have defeated yourselves
you have sabotaged your own efforts
because you know why if it takes a lie
if you have to lie about me to beat me
in an argument
then this gives me the greatest amount
of confidence that you cannot beat my
argument with a fair argument of your
own
So when you say as Douglas Murray and
others have said that I say that Hindus
are pathetic and weak
I've never once said this about Hindu
people I've said this about the hindut
for Thug gangs that were dominating the
streets and which on this very Channel
you can see walking in the streets of
Leicester with bats and knives
yes I have the videos up
yes I have the what are you gonna do
deny it
we're no longer living in an age where
you can try as journalists to dominate
The Narrative we're not in the 1970s 80s
or 90s anymore we are living in the age
of social media
your lies cannot and will not persist
it's untenable to lie in the ways that
you're lying
I must give credit to channel 4 who
actually put out somewhat of a fair
report
calling a spade a spade about the
hindutva ideology which is inspired by
fascism which of course is like Nazism
and that's why I find that a pathetic
irony that you find right-wing advocates
in this country and journalists like
Douglas Murray who are meant to be
Patriots individuals who are
anti-fascistic in inclination
that they yes are supporting such
individuals or at least trying to place
blame on the Muslim Community
because they know full well that this is
the very fascism that gave England the
biggest run for its money in the last
150 years
the the big the biggest run for its
existential money in the last 150 years
in the form of Nazi party devastated the
country and your grandparents will know
about that
but this fascism so long as this
anti-islam is was it acceptable now
has Nazism taken an acceptable form
because your hatred for Islam is greater
than your hatred for
uh for fascism
let you let you I'll let you expose
yourself you can expose yourself I don't
care just keep exposing yourselves
so what I say to you is this what I say
to you is that there is a big difference
between Hinduism as a religion or Hindus
as a people who follow this religion
and in dutva which is a an ideology
inspired by Fascism and if you don't
know what fascism is then you can go
ahead and find out but it's basically
ethnic superiority
now I do like the odd Curry myself and I
do enjoy and respect Indian culture but
I don't see a need for anybody to think
that they're better than me on the basis
of their ethnicity
I don't think Indian people are better
than anybody else in fact just as much
as I don't think that
uh any race any person of any race is
better than anyone else
you see I don't see that